now you to say where's Ferb it oh I'm in
the game what a hug what och I was in
facing him in the game ball
max I even in the game no I'm in the
game but something is horribly wrong
with my body guys have to see what I'm
seeing if you want to go yeah leave me
alone please
yeah need you later today should I stay
or should I go should I not do that stay
or should I go
hey hey Mark what not rice can you find
me do I look weird to you I can't really
see cuz I'm Slenderman and you're just
like green block fight coming up fights
a nice guy
I saw you have other monsters your house
oh okay I'm sorry should I be worried to
the slender member I should be worried
of the brick green to your teammate yeah
yeah hey Jaime I know you huh I'm not
don't worry about it oh my god I think
she's stalking me now yeah I'm stuck in
him I swear I look like some deforming
around for a second house guys look hi
uh I don't see you what you tricked me
oh geez listen to me why else would you
turn around at a slender game hey I
found a page ah page found in the whole
game by anyone I am some horrible oh my
flashlight your tater thing what a turd
my taters hater I got my taters you got
what no no I don't want any yeah yeah I
call me better get to the [ __ ]
basement and you
hahaha no hey back out no no no wiggly
wobbly
wibbly-wobbly whoa whoa stop
wibbly-wobbly ah yummy are you still
alive somewhere I'll just fake tan you
I'm dead I'm just gonna stare at this
wall ray damn it
oh please please let me view the Sun yes
oh is that great who's that
that must be you BAE oh you're female oh
I don't know which ones you well are you
by yourself Yami I'm with everyone oh
you are so just fell down feeling I hope
you know where you're going it doesn't
look like a poor defenseless woman such
as myself what the hell is wrong with my
life oh ma please please can we talk
through this okay oh it's Kelly's let me
get into the man's okay fine always way
to mock cuz I'm kind of lost
this way no turn go backwards how
backwards stairs stairs ah ah turn on
your flashlight still bad yeah you're
such a nice sentiment isn't he's like
it's like a friendly ugly senator okay
no very passive exactly I wish
Thunderman was like that more often
sure I'm not finding any pages and I've
been in LA
alright I'll leave you know you don't
trust me anymore
No get away from me I'm never talking to
you again
I'll go I'm gonna I'm actually gonna
have fun haunting you guys not try to
kill you
oh great that's what okay hey
but this is just gonna [ __ ] that's well
that's all I want to do that's what I
mean I think that's a very mean thing
today why is it mean
hi thanks who is that ha ha that's good
ha ha ha the guilt which way you're
gonna go which way you gonna go yeah you
better run run man I've gone so much
focused Here I am
thud I'm frickin stuck in the furniture
isn't this brilliant
I'm outta College vote uh please end my
misery I can't even move okay move the
table no I will I will mercy kill Yami
here please
this is what's asleep hey buddy butter
butter powder I heard that yeah this
land of death noise that I'll read with
so [ __ ] up there oh just nothing you've
been up here where are the pages having
found one I found two so far by I know a
nice little I don't know my lights out
that doctor like da da da da da da da
you go yeah right Vic's yeah all right
yeah I've aches right ray doesn't even
have any pages you know I don't I
haven't seen any all I wanted was to
sign a mock right now there's so much
fun ah
Oh boss a book what's got lots of pages
in it
uh-oh what is this why is my screen
going I don't even see you you don't see
me turn around I going up the stairs
right I was facing on the stairs just
boy yeah I should walk up then ah hey
mom you know how we're really good
friends and how how we both have an
appreciation oh yes yes I'm listening
yes yes ha ha finally oh oh god no it's
my time now good time to what you're
gonna fail you fail on us can't even
spell you won't even kill one of us
that's what you got to do I can't go
where I spun that's so [ __ ] oh there
we go
ha ha ha what a status let us let us
dream I need your kite man hold it guys
oh oh I'm getting peripheral enjoyment
out of Earth not for a full enjoyment
what you call it you know you're getting
slightly around I'm getting a contact
arousal from Tommy masses expertise in
Slenderman I'm texturized with some
yummy mush interesting yes baby oh ha ha
ha you saw the fan art you know you know
you know what's going on I also going on
I know goes on with any male youtuber
if they do a video with any other value
yeah oh yeah oh of course
so much shipping shipping so hard ship
sails where did you go where'd you go
where'd you go
no no nope nope nope nope nope nope one
of you how's it good appetizer is anyone
dead yet
I think yeah bees enjoy just a little
too much
oh no idea you have no idea how [ __ ]
you guys are right now I just get over
to pages I saved my main course for last
hey has anyone dead yet
has anyone done just do you lack not
what oh no no no no nope nope nope okay
a few I'm an expert I've done this a
million times
feels have you ever won have you ever
won no I've never
nope nope time to go outside what I
couldn't go outside there we go
going outside Oh going outside wings
he's get to be really hard to get a mess
around mom no oh you should turn around
did you just have a quick look just a
little peek alright go just half that
amount of red wolf
I don't turn around once Letterman asks
me to in the band truck ah truck or van
the the exposed oil tank a thing I can't
I didn't see it fair oh I wonder who the
Slenderman is oh ah we have we have a
Canadian sentiment that were you read
that nice I don't know about that well
if no one's the Slenderman I guess we
can all trust each other right yeah
everyone what do you want to hit the
back of that oil tanker um mark shut
[ __ ] up he's whistling great is that you
know we're all swing with is that
someone behind me I think where's behind
me oh I know you by me oh you wish who
got a page yeah I did you did I know I'm
I stood them off I feel like it I can
get like seven if I'm mr. Lane that's
hard right hey randomized are they
randomized locations are they always on
the same it's like it's like three or
four possible locations why are you
picking on me further in another one I
said up wait Yami's dead yes that yummy
you've been playing slender since
forever ago since four lungphu yes a
salivate on slender prison
even if I don't have eight out of eight
on slender that on the original slender
one a prison
the original sunder person was freaking
impossible I don't care what anyone said
I know Nicholas I was so close so many
times I was gonna time I had to give it
like a few minutes oh yeah we know we
know we were raised in the Taira but we
could never do it
I mapped it out and playing the shortest
route and invest all crazy I know good
all right I never fight them once I
didn't have the attention span hey
Marcus hey damn it know what okay I'll
let you be no oh that's not okay no why
don't you pick up we can pick on the
doll that's really mean yes do that do
that fam
how could you pick on the girl it's just
not fair do that one we gonna mark where
am I going where no oh that's where you
can don't rush
Oh God ready to pin you there's a room
of death this favor how's that it's not
fair
I buy stop fair you just don't screw it
in that one room you know way to mix the
guys yeah all right okay okay I can do
this I can do this no I don't think you
got four pages
come here come through that door right
there where you going hi yeah seriously
yeah no seriously it's okay she's right
BA he's right behind you I'm not I don't
go oh no way you're going is good
whatever you do don't turn around minx
why me hey hi you're alluding him your
luteum okay that there we go
turn around nope nope doo doo doo
yeah dad now oh so much bro
oh god that's so perfect oh those
beautiful she's got five she's doing
really good
hi how's it going Oh nope nope rage rate
is failing all over the place
oh you guys this make just she be the
first person to ever beat this game oh C
Mon guys just the first person good yes
you good ah and now this should be the
four of us right
probably I don't know Sylvania oh okay
okay just let her live the earth
yeah for that long oh man where's it
slender what the hell you don't kill me
for one second on of yeah okay one
second okay well it's been like three so
far wait who's slender and though the AI
now so orbits on a team all right
gee how come Bai has it not that one of
us cuz we all just had it and then it
cycles back to the AI yeah and then no
one can win if we're one of them yeah
it's pretty impossible right cha-cha
okay know what ages are here though I've
only found two so far I don't even
remember where they were they are pager
tricks I know they swap between my pages
no guts no other pieces access pages but
they're not oh okay how serious do this
we're doing it awesome someone got a
page
no one's Slenderman yeah well maybe I am
oh it's you you trade agent marks what
what no I'm not Slenderman I'm actually
more slender I I mean
I guess see why would I lie I'm not the
liar here
I keep getting slender little noises but
he's not here
oh he's probably glitched out we might
just kill ourselves oh that's a trick
that's a lie I know why that is a lot
yes Karen to the console off you did it
fine no so
I mean think about it think about all
that the poor babysit cleaver island I
just all the Slenderman is in the mouth
you don't need to copy is it is just
after me Oh berries halfway through the
stairs come on taught me Oh doh by light
think oh we didn't get me I thought I
got me I'm good good I can't stare into
that what what he's coming blue hair
walk your monster I'm not you're a
monster
I'm standing among you I am one of you
hi mark is not in Moline just skin burn
off like that Oh Oh am I actually a
monster I know
oh okay yeah that's why I saw that I was
all deformed oh no no no no no no come
on no no no no this like a contest
yo fast we can say no no no oh no wait
wait no no no I just stand in the store
no no mates not good for night on diet
makes I think I wait to spam to miss
though hey Gemma why face I don't
goddamnit good if you aren't gonna move
I was gonna kill myself
it would've been on your hands what
about awful I think I think I could've
dealt with it today
wow thanks I explained anyway whoever
found the new weapon others wouldn't get
it handle that yeah as it was when I was
up in the attic I didn't see it it's -
I'm killing myself
Blaire huh nothing I'm dead you fell for
yeah I'm out yeah couldn't handle the
stress
slender wood slender's been after me
this whole time
of unless thank you from him well uh who
i'm spectating Slenderman is there oh my
boobs yes number three I feel
accomplished I haven't found any makes
are you dead - yeah I killed myself okay
good
oh good job oh my god I merely see him
it's all dark I can't see anything
I don't even spend the boss actually
gonna do anything to kill anyone no yeah
Yami you're just gonna have to kill
yourself well he oh he's been coming
after me the whole time there's no
you're gonna have to go I don't want to
kill myself
come on everyone's doing it come on
buddies do my job just be part of the
group you know you go to give in to the
Christ even what I wait I haven't got
time for like one more don't have to go
alright spend him into perfect oh I
thought it was my turn oh I know
survivors if I if I die first again I'm
gonna be pissed women oh great
go what what what are you wanna tree no
you markiplier no more you look just a
little scare and if you go away
is that your Slenderman voice nice
Brennaman hey it's not very scary it's
actually quite terrifying to me hey hey
hey
tonight anything okay we're good hey
yeah me behind you I'm not not turning
Ronald stupid okay it's been around the
thing you should how about going in the
little room on the right that's it
you've heard I'm just preparing a walnut
page I always kind of page yet hey Mark
what no I'm outside you can't out me you
can't have me don't this is nice Mac no
no lies
though no don't
nope nope nope nope nope solar cell
I there's a slider man run Slenderman on
me yes Linda
hang on the cart and discussed in
account stairs okay it's nice up Harry
can you put the yeah what do you want a
cup of tea or thank you about a beige oh
I expect my cup of tea before you show
yourself though I want it with you okay
oh oh you know you can't do this aim I
got a cup of tea yeah
oh you British in your cups of tea I
think I'll go in briefly I think I'll
leave you alone like who's this in this
is the read wait no that's not me where
are you I can't what the I'm sorry
is it done sorry okay hey Mark what yeah
what night that makes you more of a
threat than yummy yeah yeah I'm not the
right eye comes out I believe you look
I'm just gonna sit here go for a swim
work
no why not yes water juice good for you
skate water spit order that's good water
so no splash around it's good water fine
something very important
who closed the door haha yes Oh got one
oh hey did you get the one in the pool
the one of the ball around her I'm Terry
turn around it Oh after you I swear
right there no come out uh-huh
got it heard about it I'm not gonna you
can't make me who keeps like dead body
like another you doing to my body
no no you don't wanna know right join me
for a swim
Flender Ryan Kenny no oh did you leave
me alone can i oh no there's no way out
don't worry about you didn't even give
me my cup of tea I can't believe nope
nope nope nope nope nope nope nope
what no nope nope nope nope I faked out
tonight Oh didn't know uh don't don't
I'm sorry guys I'm gonna have to fine
you got it lady
I need a tutorial to find out how to
pick up a ladder
ah stupid do you think I am game Jimmy
is it time it up
god
you know you know game developers good
when they put this much effort